you wrote a book called why women have
sex
understanding sexual motivations from
adventure
to revenge that sounds fun and
everything in between
so why do women have sex well i co-wrote
it with the female
who's cindy meston uh a wonderful uh
friend and colleague and coco author and
co-collaborator um i wouldn't be
presumptuous enough to write a book
called why women have sex by myself as
as as you can contribute anything to
this book uh i'm just kidding
i i i did but i have to tell you a story
about the um the origins of this idea
uh which i give credit to cindy meston
for um
and we were we would she's a colleague
in in the psychology department with me
and we would go out to dinner once a
week or so and and we were just talking
about that she raised this issue and so
we started to brainstorm
originally it was why humans have sex
that's the the scientific article we
published was why humans because we're
interested in males and females
and so i said um i would come well uh
they have sex because of x and then
cindy maestrom would come up she'd say
oh here's seven other reasons
and that i'd come up with one more and
she came up with another seven yes so it
was like
you know so she's in in some sense
importantly the um
you know originator or fountain of this
of this idea but
oh so she's able there's something about
the way she thinks about sexuality
that's able to deeply introspect about
reasons for sex yeah and probably
especially about female sexuality and
this is one of the interesting things
and why it's so fun for me to
collaborate with with um in this case
female
because they do have a different sexual
psychology than males and so and i've
noticed this that's why in my graduate
society i've had 30 or so phd students
about half of them male half of them
female
and the the the women come up with
different questions different scientific
questions that i wouldn't have thought
of necessarily
and so um and so anyway so it turned out
to be the collaboration i will i will
say that we we co-wrote it and that i
did contribute to it
and uh especially the the um the
evolutionary insights
so is there a good few words you can say
uh
to why women have sex what are some
primary motivations well we we
originally came up with a list of 237
reasons uh for why uh why humans have
sex and they range
from
you know some of the obvious ones
because it feels good uh
because i wanted to relieve stress uh
be to relieve menstrual cramps to get
rid of a headache uh to
get my boyfriend off my back so i could
get some work done yeah um so things
like that to to
others
like um
there's another one uh so that he'd take
out the damn garbage yeah
this is the one
but another one it was kind of
interesting that uh someone one
nomination was uh to get closer to god
so this there were some that were kind
of a spiritual spiritual motivations for
having sex
and then some of the nastier ones like
to get revenge
on my you know on my partner or to get
revenge on arrival so that's sleeping
with my
you know rival's boyfriend you know so
there's some nasty stuff and some good
stuff in there
it's so fascinating because yeah sex has
such a
powerful role in our psychology but also
in our culture
so you can make
a significant statements
about the in the status hierarchy
about uh
about
your sex
the selection of your sexual partner
it's interesting so it's not just
because you're horny it's all those
other kinds of things yeah warnings is
one
but there are there are other reasons